I think they'll find two things
mr. funny yes Monsieur could I speak to
you for a moment I be studying thinking
with you for some time now do you think
is worth my while to go on why do you
ask well I feel as though since my
staying here unless I have talent if you
are not certain about your talent why
didn't you stay until now because all
this is so so beautiful to me in my
youth it was all so beautiful to me but
now it is the city of Los illusions as
you studio very far no no they let us go
there you will show me what you have
done yet
[Applause]
[Music]
have you any money a little not enough
to live on
then I must tell you there is no talent
here nearly industry and intelligence
you will never be anything but mediocre
and that is very cruel to discover once
mediocrity only when it is too late I
know do you see that that name does not
belong there
it belongs somewhere else take your
courage in both your hands and make
something of your life
have you anything in mind well you see I
have my limitations my father was a
doctor I've always been interested in
medicine if I can't be great at least
one can be of some use to people
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know what I should have such a
thing upon my birth I don't I've never
entered a village in my night you've
only got to look at need to know that
it's what we call a winter cup a great
many middle-aged women heaven that's the
last thing to say to a lady no one's
ever called me middle-aged before all
right time you got used to it all fine
you're a nice one unfortunately I can't
say the same to you good day madam
that'll be all now the rest you come
back tomorrow getting ready all right
you the boy's father yes sir
what's the matter do not you see well
enough for the matter is the boy has a
club foot Oh Carrie you better take this
case to subject your dinner something
bud
it's only for the looks of the thing you
know I don't find it no trouble don't
you that's wonderful
I always did oh that's because you let
them go on at you you seem to be a
little slow Carrie I think I'll have to
instruct the class there are many
varieties of club feet this is one of
the less interesting yours would
probably prove more interesting you have
to let his acquaintance heaven show
yes I believe so termite taking over
sock to you Carrie
now zone
keeps his feet nice and clean doesn't he
hmm yes just as I thought
tella Pisa queenís malformation
requiring you to walk on the outside of
the foot a very interesting example I
must say you might have have a look at
congenital clubfoot in simple language a
foot twisted inward the cause of this
twisting is not clear hereditary
inference plays a part here as pointed
out by dr. little who traces recurring
deformity through four generations so
when you've quite finished I say old man
I like that mm-hmm
Thanks isn't she yeah she was model in
Paris you know I can't for the night
when they understand why you gave up
painting I'd rather look at that all day
long
than at this woman you know you can tell
by the pelvis yeah I like them with a
little more oh there's life in the old
girl yet don't inhale dearie I say I've
got to be getting along it's a little
matter of a barmaid at the ground anchor
and very nice to Julia a funny fella is
me oh I say Carrie it must have been
wonderful having that life in Paris oh
it was and you mean that you really knew
all those fascinating women well some of
I see you're just the man I'm looking
for
I wonder if you couldn't help me in my
way well there's a girl and I can't get
anywhere with her and you've been to
Paris and all that
I'm sure you could say something it
would give me a starter I'd asked
Griffiths only he couldn't do it and
remember whom he was doing it for oh but
you're just a man you know see something
to make her laugh
don't believe it you are
I see she's marvelous isn't she
no she's anemic
[Music]
you don't suppose she likes that bounder
do you of course
now's your chance say something
but I see your friends going I don't
know what you mean I was referring to
the nobleman with a sandy moustache has
he left you for another some people
would do better to mind their own
business
why
very nice back am i on speaking terms
with your back woman you know you can
tell by the pelvis and Beth calls in
Salford gentlemen I apologize
well for I promised you something
Charlie and she's turned our bill nature
in contemptible I'm sorry I'll let you
in for it well that's all right you know
suppose I care about the anemic little
waitress says to me do you well I do
- going coming along
no I I think I have some more tea
anything you want yes don't mind I like
to talk to you
filthy weather isn't it makes no
difference to me five to be here all day
oh don't don't like that I don't want to
say something pleasant I'll say it yep
you have a lovely smile you should use
it more often
don't go spitting no that works hot all
day like I do don't have much reason to
smile perhaps I could find a reason will
you let me try well I don't know whether
I will or whether I won't well I hope
you'll decide you will
[Music]
like that dot like so
that is the nice little hand
excuse me how do you do
you seem to be in a great honey I've
been waiting ten minutes no you could
drop that meant to be me
looks like you doesn't it if you look at
it that way
tea you are a strange sort I say dude
I'm me sometime and we'll go together I
get mine when will you come
I'm off Thursdays well actually say
Thursday 7 o'clock Victoria Station all
right I'll meet you Victoria in the
second-class waiting-room
oh please
Hey
Oh
Oh a string ticket please
19 all tickets please well I thought you
never coming after keeping me waiting I
almost went help I was in the
second-class waiting-room I thought you
said you'd be there
now I said he did lovely allison ii lost
my crew stood in the first for a
gentleman of rape you don't use them do
you perhaps not anyway you're here
though it's all right isn't it certainly
do make a girl feel important to you
[Music]
I love that music
whenever I hear it I think of you
[Music]
okay Leela exchange of cold
[Music]
you are Gillian you always old a
champagne no why'd you do it now
[Music]
I was helping you to make you more
friendly
you see it will ya it's one thing I can
say for you gentlemen every since the
word
[Music]
[Music]
Matthew again I don't mind - doesn't it
make any difference to you yeah
you don't take me out someone else will
I'll think not here
where'd you stay for a moment now why
not oh people would think I don't know
what soul
[Applause]
I love that music whenever I hear it I I
think of you whenever I hear I think of
us
[Music]
I've never danced with anyone
that's like you
my life
seems how much do your time high I
should be studying in why don't you well
I'd rather see you any of the girls
notice you're waiting for me I don't
know why what does it make
they all love that to you now do they
why say you're not with you may I call
you militant I don't mind okay don't say
that anymore will you why not well
donate I'll call you Mildred and you
call me Phillip will you I think of it I
am I'm a little awkward at this but will
you kiss me good night net Oh Mildred we
have come to deal with me on Thursday I
don't mind
Oh Charlotte Saturday certainly
[Applause]
my name is Miller emil below we should
know each other why well we are both
interested in the same same thing my
dear young man you are so so artistic
you you should be more he like you Hank
thanks very much that's that's alright
pictures
Oh what times I see you I forgot to tell
you Phillip I can't go why not
yeah
Oh
the sense in that yes but I want to go
by myself to you
I don't know Gotham to your stake well
you needn't go on about
five
you're spying on the mouth of gentlemen
every sense of the word are you going
out with Miller yeah
well what if I am I'm who I was in my
wall - can't I
he's keeping you waiting isn't he well
I'd rather wait for him than have you
wait for me
once you change your mind I'll get some
more tickets and will now
you keep looking for him the way I look
to you you don't come out to me tonight
you will never see me again good
riddance to bad rubbish
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry oh boy how about a nice large beer
wouldn't help well what would
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after leaving our for she was the waiter
who y'all he knows who you are
[Music]
and so do i what do you mean I'm sorry I
I didn't mean you're a bit too superior
to leave a fine young paint
[Music]
Maru
[Music]
what you don't like me I'm a [ __ ] go
along foolish
[Music]
my finance today you are
[Applause]
you're off your nut you don't know what
you're doing what sort of practice can
you expect to have with a wife like that
I don't know let me ask you something
why do you want to marry this girl
because I'm so in love with her ah
that ring with a little design very
popular sir we celebrate many of them
we're surprised my off you think it is
nice I was delighted well yeah yeah why
I don't know I
you've been so sweet of me all day and
I've got nothing to ask you and it makes
it so much easier for me it's easier for
me to buy something to tell you and uh
let me kill her
[Applause]
Edge's I want you to marry me didn't it
just when I was about to attend you
waited so long
is
I'm going to be there
are you
to whom and then on now yeah and Betty
good money
yes
enjoy now you won't go on about it
William
[Music]
all right I'm getting all 24 one time I
sent him down gentleman and 7,000
Whitney's got good prospects this is
goodbye I hate eating lunch enough but
Loudoun engagement I'm going to the
theater with this gentleman I'm going to
marry
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whose innocence no well London is the
largest city in the world and you know
the cure for one woman
another uh-huh right Oh
nor you know readers junk to you
no I write it what that's how I earn my
living I didn't know successful very I
have an immense popularity amongst
kitchen maids they think me so refine
[Music]
let's not talk about that
big talk about us
Nora you're not really fond of me are
you clever boy around such foolish
questions whom I did never struck me
that you could be
please delight so proud so happy until
so great I wish you hadn't been in love
with what was it
Mildred
[Music]
because if she had depleted yourself
honorably
wouldn't have taken you so long to
understand how I feel
I saw you I wasn't very quick let's go
out and say not until you pass that exam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me darling what what do you get out
of this
[Music]
you'll never know afraid you don't get
much fun with me I wish only I could
take you dancing
I know how you love it Philip it's very
silly of you to be so sensitive about
your foot you know other people don't
think about it nearly as much as you do
they notice it when they first see you
and after that they forget all about
you know I only speak of it because I
love you neither want it to make you
unhappy
[Music]
now will you please stay here and go on
cramming for that exam
[Music]
there's a 92 CS forever yet I shouldn't
have let him but she was that upset
Norah
what do you want I didn't think I'd ever
see you again
what's matter he left me emo
Oh has he
yes
because I'm going to have a baby
but why did you sit down
I suppose you want him back he'll never
come back why not
he just won't depth oh you're his wife
he has to provide for you he won't give
me anything
even if he did I wouldn't take it why
not
and what happened I've still got my
pride that's something isn't it
you got any money yep
well you better get yourself a place to
live after that me see what can be done
[Music]
you're always still good to me that's
why I knew I could come to you
now look here mr. Miller I'd like to
know what you intend to do about milord
I thought you expect me to do well I
expect you to take care of her you
married her you know I I married
Milligan I'm a ranger even one
well all the same I still like to know
what you intend to do about it me I can
do nothing when man cannot solutions a
problem of sir unmarried mark
why didn't you tell me
I just couldn't
well brace up everything will be alright
get up
do you still like me
really strange as it may seem I always
have I suppose I always shall I did
everything I could make you love me I
thought you were incapable of loving
anybody
it seems horrible to think that you were
willing to sacrifice everything for that
man I'm awfully sorry Philip I should
never forget you want to marry me
Philip yes you've been so nice to me
I'll do anything you want
will you why why I owe it to you oh do
you
you're not angry yeah
then you stay in here some dinner yes if
you want me to cross Philip nothing
could like me more Justin and I have
everything ready
Clara darling Nora how did you happen to
come just passing by
I want to rub my nose against your door
[Music]
[Applause]
why I'm not heard from you I was just
going to write why haven't you come to
see me well I have been busy
why so silent receive
[Music]
Nora I reckoning strange to tell you
you'll be so good to me it only makes it
harder
Killick what's wrong
I'm sorry it's just over I mean you
don't care for me anymore
I'm afraid sir what about down nothing
you've been wonderful to me it's just
that I
because I knew you never loved me as
much as I love you mr. president usually
case there's usually one loves one who
is family
it's always the same you want a man to
be nice to you you have to be roughen to
him you treat a man honest for you
sell it there's someone else yes
who is she
Mildred she's come back after all she's
done how could you
it's what I'd like to know just as
though you were bound or in some way
[Music]
I am to you and she was to know her
and every human being is something
another
[Music]
funny-looking little thing is dead a cop
believe it's mine now if you'll excuse
me
so glad it's over darling you've been so
good to me Philip now on things will be
different
now you will take good care of her
rupture that I will mum good day good
day I know you don't like it Philip
I can't do anything else I'm going to
work alright there's not but be sure I'm
going over on Sundays and see the babies
properly taken care of I will after
going to do this afternoon I ask you
just to come over oh did you why well I
know you'll find him amusing and I I'm
always afraid of boring you
hello hello sorry I'm late
had to get rid of a go why didn't you
bring her a lot
oh I'm not interested in my girl I'm
only interested in other man's girls do
you like me really I'm too hungry to
know but I think I like you lots
I like your lot more if you got him to
take us out to dinner tonight
and if you do I'll tell you some funny
stories and you're laughing think you're
having a wonderful time he did Oh pay
the bill I'm sorry I thought it was your
sister
[Music]
[Music]
good night Phillip good night
just a moment I even have a Mildred hi
so that's what you've been so funny
about huh while my dear alright it
doesn't matter to you Harry you've got
so many women don't take Mildred away
from me but my dear old boys is nothing
to me at all nothing at all
[Music]
do not keep in it very much so nice of
you to give it to me
thinking about you have a quite a
flirtation with Griffiths last night if
I was what not matter of fact well I
love again
I'm surprised why what do you mean
well Griffiths is good-looking he's
amusing he says the kind of things that
make you laugh ah thank you not to make
fun of me you're a bit too superior for
me in the fine young man
oh but heavens noted I wasn't making fun
of you when you serve your neck civet
serious well I don't think it is oh you
don't eh why not because Griffith isn't
in love with you how do you know I asked
him like to read a letter I got from in
this morning
I've been up all night thinking about
you now I've just sent for a special
messenger who will take this to you in
the dawn you have no notion of the time
I had with your friend last night he
kept asking me if I love you and of
course what could I say
you doubtless tell you all this so I'm
making sure that you
well how but if I love him can I know I
suppose nothing and watch it going on
about nothing only I was fool enough to
think that you cared for me I do
Philip it's a friend not in any other
way but you do care for Griffiths in the
other way but you're you're rather cold
that that sort of thing doesn't mean
anything to you that's what you think
it's now yours going on about it Philip
said yourself I couldn't help but if I'm
in love with him
well it was anything else to be said to
say it that's a nice dress you have on
Mildred I couldn't afford it but I paid
for it you have a nice apartment I
couldn't afford it but I paid you're a
gentleman
you think it slow what you've done for
me in the face do you think it matters
to me whether I'm a gentleman or not if
I were a gentleman you don't suppose I'd
care for a cheap vulgar little I'm sorry
I didn't want it in this way
Harry's waiting for me what do you
intend to do we're going to pair it get
out get out
[Music]
[Music]
I've been three times and each time this
woman's hounded me down I don't like to
do this
all right sup I'll move on come on young
lady come stay here come on
big hairy middle are all washed up and
Caliban it excuse me I'm doing the ward
hey interesting Kari I was just thinking
was an unusual name you have it's a very
holy option a once to the day is riding
the cross out of states here I have in a
Charity Hospital because my father loved
fast women and slow horses how the
mighty have fallen
hello hello father
Carrie this is my daughter christened
Maria del Sol her mother hold called her
Sally this young man is a student here
he's been very nice to me and was of
inducement he might be nice to you now
father father's particular genius of
saying the wrong thing thinks it's fun
to embarrass me
it is why don't you try it sometime
Carrie I will if I get the chance you
shall have it you're coming to see us
the first Sunday I'm home oh yes please
do
what a quaint house you give but it's
not real sanitation sanitation behind
give me odds I've got nine children and
they thrive on that range look at that
now and with great admiration
sobbing the air father's right Miguel
the sooner the better
I hope you didn't have the table in here
on my account
I'd have been quite happy to have had
dinner with mrs. definitely on the
children oh no I always take meals by
myself
I like these antique customers I don't
think women ought to sit down at a table
with men
oh don't you why not it ruins
conversation I'm so it's a bad put ideas
in their heads and women and never IDs
with themselves when they have idea you
sound like the voice of Old England I am
sir and it's this fine old Yorkshire
pudding that gives me strength to carry
on
now stop getting up not like a jumping
jack every time she comes into the room
she don't want you to make a fuss about
her do you Sally as you want to get rude
if you sit still while she waits on you
he don't get a hang for chivalry do you
Sally
no father you speak quietly while I
eating the young master boldly yes
Father you know what I'm talking about
Sonny how could I darling you're so
clever no Sam I might Jan order to make
eyes at him better get Phillip some more
hail
[Music]
my word is there anything better than
English let us thank God simple
pleasures a good appetite roast beef and
beer I was married to a lady once what
happens never marry a lady really why
because a lady is a point of view of
personality and an individuality also
w-with hang it all you want a wife who
can cook your dinner and look after your
children 36 oh sorry
although I think you talk to her leg off
the donkey well it's clean fun now Sally
wins on me I wait on you take my chair
here while I fit you and the young man
some cheese
what do you think of it you don't know
what this means to me
you see I i thankfully never had any
family this is almost any place I've
ever known that said the quality of of
home
it's no use mooning of Carrie Sally
never kisses and gentlemen Antilles VT
at twice he was ask me again sometime
Joyce yourself
why don't you come next Sunday
gestation will you know why not too late
your child 20 let's talk it over when
you're 30
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you hear what I said oh man yes I
heard sorry if I brought up a painful
subject only I thought you'd be
interested if you're about Mildred
Sascha's had such a bad time I gave her
all I could that you know me or a stony
broke
I thought perhaps you'd want to I can't
do anything cutting out a cigarette I
have a no I wouldn't have told you only
she asked me to give you her address
gave you a bit of a joke I can tell you
seeing her liking that baby around and
asking for something to eat
she has a baby with her yes it's not
difficult to imagine her next step
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
baby all right I'm very grateful to you
Philip bacala Fortas I've given you a
place of your own as it is you're
welcome to my room
I don't know what will become of me and
baby you ain't taking us in oh you don't
got on I expect what would be much nicer
to that I deserved beginning to realize
how silly I've been well you couldn't
have how you felt
let's not talk about it jelly I don't
feel like that now
okay Mildred let's have no
misunderstanding about this the reason
you're here is because I know because
you once liked me enough to want to
marry me yes well at least I can cook
for you keep you flat clean
maybe someday you'll feel better about
me things if you like they used to be
no thanks I'll smoke it later
well
goodnight
night
[Music]
man lucky came upstairs a little while
ago she said mrs. Carey she said how can
you stand it
well what's the matter of them here
indecent disgusting I calls it have
drawings of naked people about you let
me know what I think I've half a mind
take them down the cell you'll do
nothing of the kind
I love those pictures Mildred I love
them for what they were meant to be
what happened to it what way you used to
love me oh I don't know
I was disappointed so often I had so
much sighs what difference does it make
anyway
nothing only and how you got when I was
so cold to you
[Applause]
give me that way Joe SoCo to me now what
else is that
[Laughter]
he's not not anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Fareway yeah Ethel is what are you doing
up
I couldn't sleep
and you better put on something warmer
it will be alright
just let me stay here
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
still I love you sir Oh nonsense kids I
can't leave without you
please get up you're making a fool of
yourself and a fool of me I'll fail
please
I can't get on nonsense you haven't
anywhere to go stay here as long as you
like but with the definite understanding
that
you disgust me
you did it because you're crazy
you'll not see things you'll love what
they meant to be well hit what they want
miss Abby
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to be a duck
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you're leaving why the man is gone what
you intend to do anything before you go
out in the world don't you think we all
try and do something about that first
thing you'll do any good I know better
tomorrow
how are you Philip
I'm all right Semak
let's try shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
today all situations filled nothing
today nor experience I'll give you
nothing today all situation still
started innovation nothing today no
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing
[Music]
[Music]
why haven't you been to see us why don't
knowa
I've had things to do well you've been
putting on weight I'm sure you haven't
why do you say that no way you look so
oh there's only my look I'm afraid is
more than that I sent you a note last
Sunday and when you didn't answer I went
round to your room
your landlady said she had to put you
out
[Applause]
My dear follow by prearranged signal my
daughter just communicated to me
confirmation of our suspicions as you
know I've been on the beach most of my
life in fact in Tahiti Irish presidents
of the beachcombers Union and the such
I'd like to inquire into your amateur
standing where have you been staying Oh
anywhere why don't you come here false
modesty I suppose now stop being an
Englishman when a man's on his house
each time he came down in the world we
want you're here with us well I thanks
very much but don't talk trash gotta
stay here till you get your bearings and
I want no more fine talk about it it's
all the rage well well here goes my
amateur standing
I I really have no place to go it's
awfully good of you lonesome so you know
the house is completely understands day
you'll probably wind up with some foul
disease I want to talk to me well I
suppose you must be served but I must
say I'm sick and tired of serving it
nine of them
so that do looks live in mind
wouldn't be a very nice night to be out
not very now going to be jolly having
you here I hope I shan't have to stay
very long you do why I can't go on like
this you know I need a job that's right
father and I discussed that there's not
much you've everlook
I have to show that on - and father have
a job for you
as he where where you were
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right now saw you in the window
well won't you come to that very horse
third so they haven't forgotten adopt
yet no
because
that Taiwan say about and I go to a
doctor
well there's a free hospital have all
them still staring at me what seems
trouble well let's have a look at your
throat
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's not a lung
[Music]
where's the baby
one summer oh you might say you're sorry
I'm not I'm very glad
[Music]
they can't help you much
[Music]
don't leave me get up I know I've read
you're shocking without baby not yet
please
you know what I think of - you're the
only one that looks feel like I was your
one yellow gentlemen - the only one I've
ever met
[Music]
things you need
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our last day
[Music]
my celly darling
[Music]
have a so determined not to let you see
well that's sweet of you to care because
I'm going away
I suppose I'm a fool to care but it
doesn't mean you have to do anything
about it you can't help but just because
someone loves you and you don't love
back
darling do you think you'll always feel
like this about me yes
[Music]
I've known it for the first time you
came to our house for the first and I
meant something to you too
how would you do you do
[Music]
when I come back if you still feel the
same
will you marry me down
don't you mean if you still feel the
same
[Music]
[Music]
well this is what you might call the
high on their paper come on now be quick
get her out of here I don't want to like
the red on the end
[Music]
I understand this an interesting candle
here oh man don't go in there why not if
you please no use
oh I'm sorry I'm late you're not I'm not
going
[Music]
my wedding present my wife
when you intend to marry me right away
Thank You Philip my baby
no see vaguely but I am and I'm not why
the freight is only a noble gesture
that's not not married no no Sally it
isn't just there I like you far too much
to stand in your way
if you're free yes but suddenly there's
nowhere to go I had to be greed to
realize that I have to be free to
understand that all those years that I
dreamed of escape is because I was
limping through life oh thank you
because I was bound up to the person who
was incredible to me
that's all over I'm not limping anymore
of my life's all right why don't you go
[Music]
because everything that's beautiful to
me is is right here for two please marry
me Sam
if you like but don't you watch
no one else had Mary
but how about a taxi yeah